[Music]
hello yeah this is she what oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah of course I accept uh what are
the dates again
March 17 2010 okay all right great
thanks you got it stead I gotta prepare
[Music]
what do you think let's prepare for main
stage it's your time to shine if you
want to succeed then you must be very
your slides are bad but your idea is
good so you can bet before with speaker
we'll make content talked out of you
[Music]
we know about climate change but what
can you say that's new once you find the
focus then the top comes into view don't
ever try to sell something from up on
that stage or we won't pose to talk
online
[Music]
ready to practice one more time right
now
[Music]
I'll never remember all this with a
clicker work when I press it why my
still Gorgo remover
oh man I'm scared to death I hope I
don't pass out on stage and now I really
wish I wasn't
[Music]
you must be sweet like Brene brown
you must be funny like an Rosen you must
be cool like Reggie Watts and
[Music]
then I'm too nervous to give this TED
talk don't give up you're good
well edit out the message that you made
talk I will be big like Amy Cuddy talk I
will inspire like this Gilbert and I'll
talk I will engage like Hans Rosling and
release mosquitoes
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]